Guys, I think it's time to reset the simulation.
The founder of my pillow, a guy named Mike
Lindahl, a wing lunatic.
A total Trump brown nosing sycophant.
He was invited to speak yesterday at the White
House coronavirus press briefing.
And he praised Trump as a gift from God to
the United States.
If you've not heard of my pillow, maybe you
don't watch Fox News at 2 a.m..
My pillow is a foam pillow sold in infomercials
and often on Fox News itself.
And my pillow is going to retool their some
of their factories to manufacture masks for
health care workers, which is great.
That's fantastic.
Mike Lindela was invited to speak during yesterday's
press briefing and he went completely off
the rails reading a statement off of a crinkled
piece of paper that Trump is literally a gift
from God given to the United States in November
of 2016.
Check this out.
I wrote some off the cuff.
I could read this.
God gave us grace on November 2016 to change
the course we were on.
God had been taken out of our schools and
lives a nation and turned his back on God.
And I encourage you to use this time at home
to give birth to him, to get back in the word,
read our Bibles and spend time with our families.
Our president gave us so much hope.
We're just a few short months ago, we had
the best economy, the lowest unemployment
and wages going up.
It was amazing with our great president, vise
president and this administration and all
the great people in this country praying daily.
We will get through this and get back to a
place that's stronger and safer than ever.
Thank you.
Please come on.
I did not know he was going to do that, but
he's a friend of mine and I do appreciate
it.
Why did God give us Trump in November of 2016
and give us the stock market and wages and
all the stuff?
Mike's referring to?
But then give us coronavirus.
With nearly a million confirmed worldwide
cases, nearly 40000 deaths, maybe more than
40000 by the time this clip gets published.
Why wouldn't God just not give us coronavirus
to begin with and we'd all be far better off?
Oh, no, David.
How dare you.
God works in mysterious ways.
He gave us Trump and Corona virus and he gave
us Trump to deal with Carone, right?
Oh, yeah.
Sorry.
How dare I question that?
It's not funny anymore if it ever was.
Imagine having an actual president who handles
things like an adult who in December and January
takes action instead of too little too late.
In mid-March, a president who talks about
the human toll at the press briefings and
tries to connect with people and their struggles
and the fact that this is a very scary situation.
Instead, we have a president who disbanded
the pandemic response team, did nothing until
late February, early March turns his press
press briefings into promotions for exciting
new products that might appeal to Corona virus
customers as they've been referred to, while
having corporate CEOs do promos for themselves
while claiming Trump was a literal gift from
God.
We are in trouble.
And if you watch the briefings, not just of
governors here in the United States, but watch
the briefings of world leaders in other countries.
Justin Trudeau in Canada.
Emmanuel McCrone in France.
Angela Merkel in Germany.
You very quickly realize we don't have a leader
here.
We are depending on governors, the ones that
are competent to hopefully save us because
we've got no leadership coming from the Oval
Office and the gift from God rant from the
my pillow sycophant.
It's I was hoping I would wake up and that
that wouldn't really have happened yesterday,
but it did.
And this is where we are today.
We'll continue discussing this on The David
Pakman Show Instagram at David Pakman Show
while you're there.
Follow me as well.
David got packed.
We'll take a quick break and be back after
this.